ejercicios militares conjuntos entre
Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur aumentan
la atención en la Península
este simulacro de cruce de Río conjunto
que se lleva a cabo representa un puente
de la solida alianza entre la República
de Corea y Estados Unidos que podría
proteger la vida y la seguridad de
nuestro pueblo de La amenaza de Corea
del Norte en caso de emergencia y
podemos verlo como un atajo hacia una
victoria helicópteros de ataque
surcoreanos lanzaron bengalas al aire
mientras tanques blindados cruzaron el
río nam-han sobre puentes flotantes
construidos durante las prácticas por lo
tanto hemos estado haciendo una
operación combinada de cruce de brecha
húmeda donde los Estados Unidos y la
República de Corea trabajan juntos para
transportar vehículos en balsa y luego
construir un puente de recinto completo
a través de cualquier brecha húmeda muy
probablemente un puente o un río con
puentes que salen en el simulacro de 12
días de duración y que se realiza cada
año participan fuerzas blindadas de
ataque de la décima primera división
móvil del ejército surcoreano la muestra
de militar causó la ira de Corea del
Norte y como respuesta disparó
artillería el martes lanzó unos 100
proyectiles al mar frente a su costa
occidental y disparó otros 150 frente a
la costa Oriental según la agencia de
Estado Mayor conjunto del sur los
últimos disparos se produjeron sobre las
12:30 pm hora local según instalación
yang a detener estos actos que amenazan
la paz de la región